يريدون اعدامنا بهذه العباره اشتكى جنود
روس على ساحات القتال في اوكرانيا من
تكتيك وصفوه بالوحشي يتبعه قادتهم معهم
كاستراتيجيه على ارض المعركه تكتيك يعتمد
بالاساس على وحده هجوم عسكريه روسيه تسمى
بقوات الجدار او القوات المناهضه للانسحاب
هي وحدات عسكريه تتمركز خلف قوات الخطوط
الاماميه عملها الاساسي الحفاظ على انضباط
الجنود وردعهم ومنعهم من التراجع او
الانسحاب وحتى الفرار والقبض على الجواسيس
بحسب مقطع فيديو نشرته صحيفه جارديان
البريطانيه يظهر مجموعه جنود من وحده
العاصفه التابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
التي انشات في يناير للمشاركه في هجوم
موسكو الشتوي الطاحن في شرق اوكرانيا شكلت
تلك الوحده خصيصا لاختراق اكثر قطاعات
الدفاع تعقيدا في القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بعد خسائرهم الفادحه في تلك
المعركه قدم اولئك الجنود شهادات تؤكد
تعرضهم للتهديد بالقتل على يد قادتهم
واجبارهم على اعطاء اموال لقادتهم ومن
يرفض يعاقب بارساله الى الخطوط الاماميه
للقتال
لقد وضعوا قوات جدار خلفنا ولم يسمحوا لنا
بمغادره موقعنا هددوا بتدميرنا واحدا تلو
الاخر وكوحدا يريدون اعدامنا كشهود على
قياده اجراميه مهمله تماما وفقا للجارديان
فان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تسببت في
الكثير من الازمات للجيش الروسي ليس على
مستوى ساحات المعركه فحسب بل داخل صفوفه
وهو ما فسرته سابقا وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه بانه دليل على تدني الجوده
وانخفاض الروح المعنويه وعدم انضباط
القوات الروسيه